a new study by gallup shows that
people's faith
in mainstream television news is at an
all-time low
let's look at some numbers on public
meeting TV
so 10 percent now
10 percent one out of 10 people say they
have a great deal of confidence in TV
news
eight-percent say they have quite a lot
have confidence
so what you can see here is that
starting in 1983 there's just been a
precipitous decline in the amount of
people that believe
in mainstream news something happened
you know they started as a 93
but there with major drop 293 294 I'm
not exactly sure
you know what that might have something
to do with a wonder is that the
OJ Simpson that's when cable news really
went nuts that was nineteen eighty-four
and so maybe it has something to do with
that when when cable news and mainstream
news
got so sensational I does any the
surprise this seems good to me as an
online news guy
this seems all good to me cuz this is
what I've been saying for ever and this
is why I do what I do because
we can tell the truth here and we don't
have something in our year with the
network executive telling us what to say
and teleprompters
and all that so are you guys on the on
the bandwagon here this is this is all
good
this is not surprising I'll tell you
right now my family and every other
Asian family lhasa free to 95 and CBS by
connie chung
okay they were they were done they're
out cell by I
in in all seriousness in the last twenty
years you're right it is the expansion
on when
Al Gore invented the internet yes on the
two-year yeah and there is a
the he he he opened a bad the dial in to
open up and so
you don't have your middle aged white
guy now fans
your nomination well i p38 I
you know presenting you this information
is was just take to get these values
someone can tell you something and then
you'd hand
goal elsewhere too re criticisms about
it to read
other opinions differing opinions to
your argument about inform your own
and I think its this new generation of
people that worries just be a little
skeptical authority
a we're not gonna just take the
broadcast newscasters
at happy Saha do you think this is more
because
mainstream news just socks or because on
my knees
is good or maybe you don't agree with
enough I think both
and a like I mean I don't think it's
surprising to anyone it's not news to
anyone
I newspeople trust media I may have gone
down a lot
but as far as the air echoes that hasn't
been a very well trusted
no idea either yeah I mean if not as
well now I think finally
that TV news has dropped below the
Internet read the internet never really
been incredibly high
either and I mean a first newspapers
goes that smile the people are not at
her high but the
yeah yeah I mean like newspapers are the
most trusted
but the amount of circulation apply
printing new newspapers and stuff like
people are doing that anymore it's gone
down so much there
they actually think it might not even be
a fitting in five to 10 years anymore
yeah I'm so I really think internet is
going to be the biggest
former media and its I mean I know
there's a lot of troll website
there's a lot of misinformation out
there everybody knows anyone can go on
Wikipedia and edit
I think my party that has kinda made
people more distrustful
the internet but I mean there are so
many different other than you can go to
that have
in a research in peer-reviewed articles
just take a little bit of work break so
how do you do that because there is so
much so that i think is the interesting
part you know you have three cable news
channels
and one's working for the democratic
party was working for the
Republican Party and I don't know what
CNN CNN still at the plane
the but what what do you do because
there's so much in three how do you
decide who to trust its top right
yeah it's true I mean when it depending
on what the issue is I always
read the different opinions as mentioned
earlier and Ikes I guess
and bounced off my own moral compass
right what do I believe in what's
important to me
and then I take from it what I well I
mean unless the
are you implying that the newscasters
like you-know-who members reading and on
the news is replying to you know
well their old owned by giant
corporations
deli ham dollars and I just gonna say
there's a very small group of people
the control pretty much ninety percent
of what you see yeah on the news
so I mean if you actually see different
videos of people have lined up
the introduce like the introductory
segment two different news
I shows and they all say the same line
Mike for each other like our hockey this
year
but but but but like everyone says the
same thing at the same time thing here
yeah but unlike and I saw that we were a
lot of these were placed together so
it's almost like they're all scripted
in a different way and and you like that
is that's gonna shake up its a lot
because
its all planned out they're all saying
the same things and even whenever they
disagree kinda wonder
was that planned like that I don't think
there's necessarily
the secret COBOL a five guys they're
sitting in a room disseminating this
information because as crossing and said
extraordinary claims require to any
evidence and I know everything that I
although it seems like it but that's not
evidence right seeming is not evident
that's not speculation I wish dance yet
but is there is there anyone in the
mainstream news that when you watch you
trust them I don't think they're sitting
there live like I don't think people are
necessarily like caught in a
know something for sure I mean cause you
watch Chris Matthews I'm is an easy he
said every opinion
about everything and and discounts what
he says the week before constantly
so I yes some of them are lying but all
the rest them I think you're just
on the mir they're just TV people who
hand someone has a theory to imagine
is there anyone that you watch that you
really in the mainstream use the way to
you really feel like it's an absolutely
not
yeah now I get all my information from
the Internet and if it's something that
seems sketchy to me I'll definitely look
further into it
yeah you know i i I use more than one
source and
TV just does not seem like something
that I would ever want to use
you crazy night and I have one source
geez
something I shouldn't have faith and
okay right and I magnin husband alive
tomorrow
yeah email yeah rooting interest
there's some interest that we all know I
damaging Cooper using them on FB
he is he's a good interviewer and I
don't think he's naturally present
information I think he's just
asking the hard questions with regards
to whoever is prominent in the media
but does not edit mine is a green us all
those in a sec I like this diane sawyer
I like everyone good morning america.
team cuz they're fine and you know and
and they're generally
really hard if I want something serious
hitting you know something
I will I will turn to a more credible
like online newspapers
in with the more investigative angle and
by the way he won an example of what you
were talking about about how it seems
like they're all doing this in cahoots
with each other
you know net neutrality which we in the
Young Turks talk about constantly which
is really basically
pretty much after the NSA the most
important thing that's happening in the
country right now because we need equal
access
to the internet so that these giant
corporations can start throttling what
you can and can't watch
the network news and even caymans barely
covered it all
we covered here cuz it's important to us
but that's the whole point
because eventually they could start
slowing it down for us and then you'd
only get your information from the very
same people who are covering
so filthy rivers there's I so many times
as he something huge going on you know
somebody being
you know persecuted another country for
the lacquer beliefs are different
beliefs and that never on the news
the only time I ever get that
information is because it's you know
something that on my aim friends are
posting on twitter
earlier you know it's like the
information that I find it incredibly
important wanna times has nowhere to be
found here it happen to remember
maybe when he's out in a row so when the
whole thing was happening in Egypt into
rear square
in-band we were showed but CNN all day
was showing that
fucking trial does anyone remember what
trial that was
anyone there was some stupid I know just
some trial another trial than they had
this story is no I didn't know I am in
there was a woman that I'm sure killed
somebody or sumthin sumthin
I CNN with literally showing the trial
there is nothing
more dribble s and my new show based
then showing
eight hours to trial and CNN was showing
two rear square
in a little box while they were showing
the trial and nothing happens in
in a trial do all day long ago bottoming
anyhoo I hope you learn a little
something here and that you thought we
were being honest because that's what
we're trying to do